- So I want to take a second
and look at some egregious
but also unintentionally
hilarious police misconduct.
(door slams)
All right, so the policeman
enters the garage,
and then he just slams it into the car.
Slams it again.
Just...
(host sighs deeply)
Yeah, it goes without saying,
this is entirely improper,
but I do want to highlight a
hilarious comment on Twitter
from Brian Hamilton who highlights
a kind of passive pro police speech
you often hear describing
conduct like this.
"A car was damaged today
in an officer-involved door slamming.
The car's manufacturer
says it was a good car
but the Carfax shows a
more complicated past."
Yeah, even when there's videos,
sometimes people have
to both sides things,
even when one of those
things is a car probably.
(door slams)